This is Jocko podcast number
51 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
Forgotten.
The Korean War is often referred to as
the forgotten war and it's sandwiched
between deep,
massive world war two and
then on the other side,
the highly controversial and also
highly televised and therefore highly
remembered Vietnam War.
So I guess in that middle of that,
the Korean War somehow gets lost
and I guess somehow gets forgotten.
No,
obviously we should never forget.
The war in Korea was brutal.
And in many ways when you
look at the Korean War,
you see the worst parts of these,
all other wars,
you had the trenches of world war one,
you had the bitter cold of the
eastern front. In World War II,
you have the landmines of the Vietnam War.
And for the nearly 2 million that served
in Korea and the more than 100,000 that
were wounded,
we should never forget.
And we must never forget.
And for the 36,516
Americans that were killed.
We must always remember
always and remember that
for those that died,
there is nothing else.
There's nothing else.
They gave everything.
Everything they gave for a few meters
in between trenches are for hill or for
their brothers in arms.
That's what war does.
That gives everything to som
and it takes everything from others.
Okay.
Tert tonight we begin to take a look at
the Korean War through the eyes of James
Brady,
United States Marine Corps
in his book the coldest war.
Yeah.
What job are you looking for?
I knew the answer and snapped
it back. Rifle platoon leader, sir.
The major said that I was a hard charger,
that they needed hard chargers in the
basic school in Virginia where they
trained marine lieutenants, they ask
you every few hours that same question.
Then they push a form at you to write down
your four first three choices of duty.
There are several schools of
thought about this one held.
You should tell the truth.
Those who subscribe to this odd notion
put down communications or tanks or
mountain training.
Anything that might delay assignment
to a replacement draft and the war.
Another advise diplomacy,
a first choice of rifle platoon
leader to show your spirit.
Then what you really hope for
logistics or motor transport.
A third school felt you should lie.
Brazenly indicating ferocious demand
for a rifle platoon on grounds that this
might impress people and get
you made a general's aide.
Mac Allen achieved something of a name
at basic school by stipulating quite
honestly, each time. Rifle platoon
leader, rifle platoon leader,
rifle platoon leader.
I didn't worry about it much,
not out of fatalism,
but simply because I believe the marine
corps discarded all such forms without
reading.
And it didn't matter much what you wrote
this close to the line. I
was too embarrassed to give
any answer, but the one,
the major obviously wanted to
hear splendid, said the major,
we have an opening for a hard charger.
Second Battalion Colonel Gregory's
battalion. They want, yeah.